en medio de la crisis de venezolanos que
intentan llegar a Estados Unidos México
está ejerciendo de muro de contención no
obstante con la migración alcanzando
niveles récord el gobierno mexicano
sugirió retomar relaciones entre Estados
Unidos y Venezuela rotas en 2019
es necesario
que
se restablezcan las relaciones de
gobierno de Estados Unidos y el gobierno
de Venezuela es indispensable la semana
pasada Estados Unidos anunció la
concesión de entrada humanitaria a
24.000 venezolanos en un intento por
frenar la oleada de migrantes que cruzan
de México a Estados Unidos la mayoría
después de una peligrosa travesía por
Centroamérica pero esta medida no parece
ser suficiente
este vamos a ir
solicitando que se entreguen más Y es
que tras un acuerdo con México los
venezolanos que cruzan ilegalmente a
Estados Unidos se exponen a ser
devueltos a suelo mexicano en una
estrategia muy similar a remake México
de la administración de Donald Trump en
Ciudad Juárez en las organizaciones
humanitarias esperan a los que han
corrido esa suerte para intentar
satisfacer sus necesidades básicas
algunos comentan que tenían dos tres
semanas sin bañarse
otros decían que tenían pues ya un
bastante rato sin comer bien o algunos
comentaban que les quitaron su calzado
cuando intentaron cruzar Y pues ahora
valorada mucho más el calzado quizá que
la comida la falta de diálogo entre
Caracas y Washington complica la
repatriación de venezolanos para los
venezolanos era mucho más probable
quedarse en Estados Unidos hasta la
medida del 12 de octubre porque era muy
difícil devolverlos a Venezuela